غزه في كل حته ها القدس لان اه احنا مش
ناسيين حد في غزه الناس بتبعت رسائل كتير
قوي تقول انت نسيتونا لا لا ما نسينا احنا
ما نسي نكوش احنا لا نملك الا الدعاء
والكلام
عنكم في غيرنا جماعه لا سمح الله هم اللي
يملكوا الامر انما احنا احنا بندعي ربنا
سبحانه وتعالى يكون في صفكم وينصركم ان
شاء الله انتوا شرف الامه انتوا فوق راسنا
فاحنا مش ناسينكم انتم خليتوا الواحد يحلم
انه يصلي في الاقصى كنت دايما اقول كل
الاجيال اللي ورانا انتم خليتونا تحلم ان
احنا نروح نصلي في المسجد الاقصى والله
والله انتوا شرف واحنا بدعيلكم ما بن سكوش
خرجنا بره النص انما زي ما بقوللك
الامريكان مبوظين كل حاجه الامريكان
رايحين مع الظلم فانتم حسبوا ف الامريكان
احنا لا احنا خلاص الجيل كشفكم امريكان
بريطانيا المانيا كله ال كشفته اصبر بقى
على الجيل اللي جاي والاجيال اللي جايه
هتشوفوا الاجيال ملتزمه بقيامها وعقيدتها
وايمانها الصح مش الايمان اللي انتم
عايزينه تفصيل التفصيل لا احنا فاهمين نا
كويس صح وعقيدتنا صح وبناء على العقيده
والدين احنا بنتصرف ولا نتقي الا وجه الله
والاخلاص انتم فوق راسنا وانتم شرف الامه
وربنا سبحانه وتعالى يكون في عونكم وربنا
يصبركم
ه